when it comes to guns how do the US and
Canada differ let's start with gun
homicides in Canada guns killed 131
people in 2013 in the US guns killed
over 11,000 people in the same year
that's a rate 9 times higher than our
neighbors to the north and it's not like
Canucks don't own guns Canada ranks 13th
in the world for rate of gun owners the
u.s. ranks number one one thing Canada
doesn't have a powerful gun lobby like
the NRA which in 2014 spent over 32
million dollars on political spending
then there's the gun laws the ones up
north are stricter and more complicated
than in the u.s. in Canada every single
gun owner must be licensed in the US
there is no federal license for gun
owners in Canada you must register your
semi automatics and handguns with a
government in the US there are more
states that prohibit all gun
registration than states that have a
form of gun registration in Canada you
can only carry a gun in public if it's
for your occupation or in limited cases
if you need it to protect your life in
the US you can legally carry a concealed
gun in every state and openly in most
others and in some places you can do
this without a permit in Canada
background checks are done through a
centralized database that has criminal
information from each province in the US
the FBI database is spotty sometimes
missing local criminal and mental health
information so should Americans adopt
the Canadian approach to guns